[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 17 8 culture une
émission pour vous présenter à les
projets culturels dans les yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui la maison elsa
triolet aragon a rendu hommage à
l'autriche elsa triolet pour les 50 ans
de sa disparition un timbre à son
effigie était présenté samedi à lens en
domicile à de l'artiste et pour rendre
la culture accessible la ville de
plaisir organise les seins pointus un
mois d'animations ponctuelles au coeur
de la ville
au programme déambulation musicale
signer drive manège ou encore au théâtre
et puis une balade artistique en vallée
de chevreuse c'est ce que vous propose
de l'association hélium avec son
événement et d'un arbre à l'autre
découverte des oeuvres de cinquante six
artistes en plein air sur un parcours de
4 5 km et je vous le disais en titre
pour les 51 ans de sa disparition ce
mercredi 16 juin la maison elsa triolet
aragon a rendu hommage à l'autre is le
timbre à l'effigié des la triolet a été
présentée samedi 12 juin à l'ancien
domicile de l'artiste
c'était en présente en présence de
représentants du groupe la poste un
reportage d'astrid bergère et nicolas
landry une nouvelle hauteur va faire son
apparition sur les enveloppes des
français un timbre à l'effigié de
l'écrivaine elsa triolet a été dévoilée
pour marquer les 50 ans de sa
disparition une présentation dans la
propriété de l'artiste à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines elle rejoint
son époux louis aragon qui avait eu son
timbre en 1991
au total 480 15000 exemplaires seront
tirés une édition limitée disponible
dans deux mille bureaux de poste depuis
le lundi 14 juin qu'on annonce une un
tirage ce thème sera en vente pendant 12
mois et qu'il soit vendu ou non à la fin
il sera de toutes façons retiré du
marché la demande date l'été 2010 9 et
fait l'objet d'une confirmation en
septembre 2019
cette demande a été formulée par la
direction de la maison elsa triolet
aragon
né en 1896 elle s'est engagée dans la
résistance pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale elle a écrit une trentaine
d'ouvragés et en 1945 elle à triolet et
récompensé du prix goncourt pour son
titre le premier accroc coûte 200 francs
c'est un nom qui est connu
mais souvent il n'ya que ce nom qui est
connu et on connaît moins leur parce
qu'on connaît son nom à travers aragon
alors qu'on n'est pas toujours aller
jusqu à la lecture de cette oeuvre est
une grande oeuvre et on voulait saisir
l'occasion cet anniversaire pour se
piquer la curiosité on est certain que
ceux qui seront suffisamment curieux
pour ouvrir les pages en ouvrirons
d'autres pour la première femme à avoir
obtenu le prix goncourt ce timbre est un
véritable hommage une mise en lumière
pour le 51e anniversaire de la
disparition d'elsa triolet
elle a quitté ce monde le 16 juin 1970
elsa triolet qu'il fait partie à des
femmes qui ont marqué les yvelines le
triste souvent associé à son époux louis
aragon s'est démarqué de son vivant avec
une trentaine d'ouvragés aussi son
investissement c'est surtout la première
femme lauréate du prix goncourt retour
sur son parcours avec ce sujet
d'archivés de mélanie poké regarder je
sais pas combien il ya eu de femme ma
ville de niort
j'ai jamais compté mais il y en a eu
qu'une
cette femme c'est elsa triolet l'autrice
disparaît le 16 juin 1970 au moulin de
villenave où elle vit avec louis aragon
le temps s'arrête et le monde artistique
et lui rend hommage depuis les années
elsa triolet est malade et donc on
s'attend si je puis dire à ce qu' elle
puisse mourir
d'ailleurs mais elle même si à temps il
ya des angoisses du coude et d'aragon et
d'elsa par rapport à la mort possible et
proche des les arts et lettres
françaises le journal devait aragon orne
au grand dam de madère culturel va faire
un numéro entier qui publiera les
réactions des plus grands dans le monde
entier
né en russie à moscou dans une famille
de la bourgeoisie lé 12 septembre 1896
elsa triolet s'appelle alors el-ayoun
avenas cagan des plus jeune âge sa soeur
lily est elle-même par le français et
allemand couramment on est encore dans
cette réussite
voilà dans une époque où l'élite par les
français et elle dès le plus jeune âge à
commence à écrire aussi en français son
premier lien avec la littérature son
histoire d'amour avec un romancier russe
victor clause qui publient leurs
échanges épistolaires des lettres repéré
par maxime gorki des écrits d'abord en
russe puis en français elle à triolet
écrira près d'une trentaine d'ouvragés
jusqu'au rossignol se tait à l'aube ne
s'est pas de la boulimie ya une vraie
réflexion et surtout comme le français
n'est pas la langue maternelle est
toujours une conquête par rapport à par
rapport à cela dope non c'est même cédé
moment d'accélération
malgré tout c'est quand même une
écriture qui est très pensée 2 au 2e
tour le prix est décerné à madame elsa
triolet pour son livre le premier accroc
en coûte 200 francs un prix goncourt
décerné en 1945 pour l'année 1944
elle est la première femme à l'obtenir
parfois il ya des mauvaises langues qui
vont dire que l a eu le prix goncourt
parce que c'est une femme
alors c'est la double peine c'est à dire
que non seulement votre oeuvre minoré en
permanence et cantal est enfin reconnu
on dit que ce n'est pas l'oeuvre en
question mais que c'est que c'est votre
sexe qui est roi récompensé quatre
nouvelles composent l'ouvragé la
première les avants d'avignon paraît
clandestine aux éditions de minuit en
1943 il se trouve qu'à l'aide afin d'en
juive donc pour les nazis elle est
considérée comme juive et qu'elle est
d'origine russe et qu'elle en plus des
orientations politiques qui sont
combattus à ce moment là et elle va
mettre sa plume au service de la
résistance à travers des articles de
presse ou des enquêtes de presse qu'elle
va faire pour la presse de la résistance
ou aussi à travers des romans ou des
nouvelles elsa triolet est aussi
indissociable de son époux qu'elle
rencontre en 1928 le poète romancier et
journaliste louis aragon tous les deux à
leur encontre étaient dans une dans un
désarroi sentimental c'est pour ça que
dans ses rôles dans ses romans et dans
ses poèmes d'après ce que des officiels
zappe
il repose dans leur propriété yvelinoise
les ouvrages d'elsa triolet sont
aujourd'hui traduit dans une dizaine de
langues
autre hommage cette fois ci pour
frédéric dard à l'écrivain a vécu aux
mureaux pendant une vingtaine d'années
pour les 100 ans de sa naissance la
ville organise plusieurs événements
parmi lesquels un tour en petit train à
la découverte des lieux emblématiques de
la ville qui ont marqué a justement la
vie de l'auteur et ça se passera donc le
dimanche 27 juin le train partira de la
médiathèque plusieurs créneaux sont
proposées une balade artistique en
vallée de chevreuse c'est ce que vous
propose l'association hélium jusqu'au 31
août découverte des oeuvres d'une
cinquantaine d'artistes une alternative
aux expositions est traditionnel célia
gars de saint gobain soir au sort est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter cette
exposition où est-ce qu'on peut la
retrouver précisément d'un arbre à
l'autre c'est l'exposition le nom de
cette exposition en plein air qui durera
trois mois on peut découvrir environ 70
oeuvres depuis la gare du rer b de saint
rémy les chevreuse jusqu'à boulet les
trous en et seule sa part de la gare de
saint rémy en fin de l'aiguillage
exactement et il y a une qui s'appelle
une voix douce qui est l'ancienne voie
de chemin de fer qui allait de
saint-rémy aso et qui fait du km5 et qui
que l'on a investi en mettant des
oeuvres d'art tout du long
l'événement est organisé par
l'association hélium elle réunit une
centaine de plasticiens des musiciens et
quelques danseurs qui sont en vallée de
chevreuse
les artistes ont travaillé autour d'un
thème précis l'environnement la forêt
les oeuvres doivent s'intégrer dans cet
environnement naturel avec des
installations éphémères ou pérennes et
en même temps il n'y a pas que des
manifestations et aussi un certain
nombre d'ateliers
c'est à dire qu'on accueille des gens
pour faire des choses avec eux on a
aussi organisé des rencontres avec les
écoles pour que les enfants viennent
voir des carnets d'activités pour les
enfants pour que tout ça soit soit
vivant tout du long
l'été est donc ce sont 56 artistes qui
ont travaillé sur cet événement oui dont
cécile bourgois audic sculptrice et
plasticienne pour cette balade
artistique et elle a composé de deux
oeuvres lune qui se nomme crépuscule
d'un chêne se trouve suspendu entre deux
chaînes devant la fondation de coubertin
sur le chemin avant de rentrer vraiment
dans la forêt et l'autre se trouve dans
la forêt là j'ai choisi de faire une
prise de vue d'une installation qui
comporte beaucoup de personnages et
c'est une installation de toutes petites
statuettes et qui deviennent donc dans
la forêt d'immenses ce poumon silhouette
puisqu'en fait le jeu avec avec les
bâches c'est qu'on peut utiliser de nos
deux heures dans les allées transformant
par le jeu de de la reproduction
la copie est donc si l'on veut plus
d'explications il existe aussi une
application mobile
oui une application géolocalisée sur
smartphone pourra renseigner les
visiteurs sur les oeuvres proposées
sinon pour plus de renseignements toutes
les explications sont à retrouver sur le
site de l'association hélium et durant
ces trois mois des temps forts au sombre
seront programmées comme le dimanche 27
juin au molière où vous retrouverez des
animations et des spectacles
merci celi agathe son goût d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
je rappelle journalistes pour tv 78 les
lalanne aprilia non à trianon oui pardon
c'est une autre exposition en plein air
qui vous est proposée par le château de
versailles elle les sculptures des
artistes claude et françois xavier
lalanne sont à découvrir dans les
jardins du château jusqu'au 10 octobre
et du 30 mai jusqu'au 4 juillet la
commune 2 plaisir organise un mois
d'animations ponctuelles au coeur de la
ville au programme déambulation musicale
signer drive manège ou encore au théâtre
le festival des impromptus investi la
ville
objectif rendre la culture accessible un
reportage et d'astrid bergère et
bérangère bourgoin sur le marché dans
les parcs les rues où même les centres
commerciaux cette année les plaisirs aux
as peuvent rencontrer la culture en
sortant de chez eux on a décidé de
mettre en place une manifestation qui
s'appelle les impôts
on tue qui est une manifestation qui
permet justement d'être d'être là et
dans les quartiers c'est à dire au lieu
de faire venir tous les habitants au
même endroit pour des raisons sanitaires
que vous comprenez eh bien on explose
les manifestations dans l'ensemble de la
ville dans les différents quartiers y
compris dans les centres commerciaux
puisque beaucoup de gens y sont
l'objectif remplacer le festival
habituel escale d'ailleurs qui rassemble
chaque année plus de dix mille personnes
au programme de la première édition
musiciens danseurs comédiens nous sommes
dans le parc du château
on a un très beau manège on a des
déambulations avec et danses sur
échasses
on a aussi des girafes qui ne sont pas
vraies mais qui semble être vrai il en a
beaucoup de beaucoup de musique et de
fanfares aussi au travers de la ville au
total ces 159 artistes qui se
rassemblent pour les impromptus qui
viennent du monde entier
ce qu'on peut voir ici c'est une partie
du gros gap la danse c'est un peu basé
sur des influences espagnoles avec des
chorégraphies démarches parfois nous
arrêtons les chorégraphies avec de la
musique espagnole
on donne beaucoup de musique et de
couleurs avec ses festivals en so cute
je pense que cet environnement est
vraiment beau avec les costumes rouges
et le château en arrière-plan les
plaisirs oies sont ravis et au rendez
vous
voir le spectacle sera remplacé escale
d'ailleurs et je sais pas plus mal comme
ça il y en a un peu dans toute la ville
très agréable
pas de lieux communiqué ni d'horaire le
but est de ne pas créer de gros
rassemblements mais de petites surprises
au coin des rues pour les habitants de
plaisir et parmi les autres spectacles à
venir un concert et des liasses grise
dans le jardin du musée départemental
maurice denis de saint germain en laye
la session live et en partenariat avec
la clé est prévue samedi à 19 juin à 15
heures
le chanteur sera accompagné d'un
guitariste au programme musique pop folk
et puis à andrésy la bibliothèque
saint-exupéry en partenariat avec le
théâtre de sartrouville présente et
cabaret carver une mise en scène de
nouvelles de l'écrivain américain
raymond carver
ce serait à la salle rameau de l'espace
saint-exupéry samedi à 19 juin à 19h30
et c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8
culture merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
très bonne soirée et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]